what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 8th of march
the uncle joey's joint is brought to you
by draftkings it's the [__] week
march mayhem is [__] here alley-oop
[__]
it's march and that means it's time for
the biggest college basketball
tournament
of the [__] year to celebrate
draftkings is going
completely [__] insane you ready for
this one here it is
you bet four dollars as an underdog if
they win
you're up 256 dollars that's [__]
madness
all it takes is four bucks to get you a
shot at winning 256
bucks the [__] bank is open if
anybody knows about betting an underdog
it's your uncle joey look at me now i
was an underdog at one time
there's no better way to put your
college basketball knowledge to the test
than putting your money where your mouth
is at draftkings sportsbook right now
college bowling for you
draftking sportsbook offers great odds
and promotions on golf
hockey nba mma
whatever you need they got for you who's
[__] better than them
nobody download the top-rated draftking
sportsbook app now
use promo code joy when you sign up to
turn
four dollars into 256 dollars
if the underdog of your choosing pulls
off the upset
that's code joey to turn four dollars
into 256 dollars
for a limited time only at draftkings
sportsbook
here's the part the lawyers make me say
you got to be 21 older
if you're younger than that go [__]
yourself new jersey indiana
pa only new customers only restrictions
apply
see draftkings.com sportsbooks for
details
now if you have a gaming problem call
1-800 gambler
or 1-809 with it if you're in indiana
but if everything's clear and you're
down and you're ready to make some money
go download the draft king sportsbook
app today
right now right now it's monday and
there's action tonight on the nba
there's got to be something going on bet
small whatever you want
but you can't miss out on this deal you
bet four dollars
on the underdog if they win you're up
256 dollars
that's [__] insane download the
draftking sports book app now
and tell him uncle joey sent you preston
joey
the joint is also brought to you by blue
chew
the blue bird of happiness came to me
this monday morning and whispered in my
ear
for harder stronger [__] elect
erections
get blue chew if you want your dick to
be in combat [__] form
you gotta get some blue chew blue chew
brings you the first chewable
dick pill same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis
at a fraction of a course this isn't
that [__]
snake wall they sell you at the [__]
liquor store the guy don't even [__]
have blowing glass
blue chew is an online prescription
service no visits to the doctor's office
no awkward conversations no [__]
waiting in line at the pharmacy
sign up at bluetooth.com talk to one of
the licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you receive
your prescription within days
and i got a special deal for you you
ready for this one
try blue chew free when you use promo
code joey at checkout
just pay five dollars for shipping
that's it that's bluechew.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month
free free free and as always
i want to thank blue chew for sponsoring
the joint but
try blue chew for free go to blue chew
right now and use promo code joey at
checkout
and just pay five dollars for shipping
all right blueshoot.com
right now press and code joey and get
your dick
and tip top magoo [__] shape muscles
everything it's gonna look [__]
tremendous the joint is also brought to
you by
cbd lion whether it's a thousand
milligram extra strength cream
the kinesiology tape now they have pills
little
i mean listen go to cbdline.com
read up on cbd and how it can help you
they have milk chocolate if you want to
put it through your lungs they got the
vapor pen
if you want to put it on your knee the
way i did use the kinesiology tape
the tropical gummies are [__]
tremendous the raspberry gummies are
[__] tremendous
they got a [__] bath ball that you
throw in the bath and you could soak
your knees your shoulders
you know i mean listen cbd lion is
tremendous
i've been talking to you about them for
the last [__] three years
and now it's battle tested they helped
me survive a [__] surgery
i'm off to pain medication thank you cbd
lion
go to cbdlion.com right now and press in
church
or joey and get 20 off your order
delivered right to your house no more
buying [__] cbd at a liquor store
or at a shoe store you're safe here with
uncle joey
go to the cbd line i want to thank cbd
line i want to thank
[__] uh bluetooth and i want to thank
draftkings let's get this [__]
party started [__]
here we go
it's monday [__] you got a second
chance of being a [__] savage
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Applause]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 8th of march
was a great weekend i'm happy you're
here the fights were great i mean it was
[__]
i couldn't ask for a better weekend my
knees feeling a lot better
i uh last week was weird because i
worked so hard over the weekend the gym
and then pt on monday and wednesday and
podcasts and all that [__]
[__] thursday and friday i mean
thursday i worked out but friday
i was [__] dead the week caught up
with me and then sadly i didn't do much
sunday i didn't do much i watched the
honeymooners with the girls and [__]
uh but the good news is
i'm off the pain pills a week now it's
official we made it through with no
addictions
i gave the pills to my wife just in case
to hold there's tons of them left
uh i'm happy to get over that the knee
still
today's a two year anniversary of the
[__] surgery so
we made it over the [__] hump my leg
hasn't fallen off every day i'm walking
i think my knees are just detached i'm
gonna look down and see my [__] leg
from the knee down
just sitting there i swear to god i get
the weirdest [__] things
but uh i'm all right we made it i'm
happy i did it and uh we're here for
another fun-filled week
on the [__] podcast i went back to
zoom today i had such
a great time last week on zoom seen doug
on zoom and i
saw that you guys enjoyed it listen
i never liked the one man and and i hope
this doesn't go wrong with anybody when
i'm saying this
i love bill burke i'm a i'm a big fan of
bill birth
always have been always will be i always
start doing though
i always thought doing the one man thing
was overwhelming
me being by myself but i had to work
through it during the coven
if not i would just be a [__] dead
mute so i figured that's the best way to
do it and i would do it with zoom
i think with zoom at times the love gets
lost like if you're not
if you don't have a stable relationship
with that person you can't see it
through zoom
but i've been wrong uh before uh i
really enjoyed the standhold podcast
personally as a human being i enjoyed it
i enjoyed watching it the feel of it i
guess it's what it's going to be from
now on for a while until
we can have guests in here you know i
live an hour from the city so
not a lot of people are going to be
voluntarily raising their [__] hand
to come down here so my plan was always
to get an
office up north and have guests that was
always the plan
but with the covert and [__] like that
it's it's too rough i saw it on people's
faces in l.a it's rough to
you know thank god we had the door and
thank god it was
face to the outside the office wasn't a
building you know
that made it a lot easier to get guests
but during this now
it's it's hard to inflict it's hard to
can you imagine if you bring a guest in
and he gets sick and he brings it home
and gets his family sick a couple people
got sick from doing podcasts they got
together like
big bunches and they got sick from
podcasts and that's why i'm against it
but once
[__] i don't i don't i don't i don't
want you guys to think i'm doing the
podcast solo
because i i think i'm not [__]
interesting i'm the man's most century
the world's most interesting man no no
it's not based on ego or anything that's
why
whenever i saw somebody doing an hour
podcast
or two by themselves i'm like [__] it
takes a lot to think that people want to
hear you
for [__] two hours but there's no
stand-up comedy now so
it's like [__] stealing it's like
just doing two hours of stand-up comedy
here
but at the end of the week it's three
months you're just seeing my [__]
ugly face every [__] monday and
wednesday
so you gotta get somebody else in here
so today we went over to zoom
and we had a nice intimate chat with our
brother uh dean delray we talked
i saw that he uh tweeted to rhino
records on saturday about black sabbath
uh rhino records is having like a a
march madness
like a march heavy metal madness month
or something like that it's called
so they sent me some great albums they
sent me uh they were the ones that sent
me volume four
and they sent me uh uh
heaven and hell and the mob rules by
black sabbath all james deal albums then
they haven't released him humanizer yet
but
they did release uh mob rules re-release
so they sent them to the house so when i
saw that dean
retweeted i called him right up and i go
you know i got to believe this rhino
sent me those two
and you know i listened to him in hell
and i listened to the mob rules
both nights this week like i i was
telling dean during the podcast you guys
will hear that
my wife goes to bed early some night
she's [__] tired my wife is over here
cleaning the house taking care of me
and taking care of my [__] daughter
she's tired so
instead of just sitting there and
watching tv during this pandemic i
figured out that i
would just bring a notebook at night
come back here i sit back here
just like i'm doing a podcast i put my
feet up and i put an alma and i listen
to
have it in hell and it's just it was
just tremendous and then the mob rules
i forgot that dean had always said to me
that his favorite song
was the sign of the southern cross i
listened to that and i was like
jesus [__] christ i forgot how great
those albums were and this is all part
of the
the comedy catch-up that you know you
know like i was telling dean you guys
will see i
i put so much of myself into comedy that
i lost
touch with music and then over the years
with the podcast
once i got re-connected with music
that's what cleared my mind a little bit
and that's what got me back here
so anyway instead of me talking any more
[__]
uh i want to present dean delray to you
all right
that's it and that's that i hope you
[__] enjoy it i'll be back afterward
to check in with you and read you on the
way out enjoy it
welcome my friend how are you dean del
rizzi i'm good how about you
good to have you on uncle joey's joint i
miss you to death
you know it's good to see you listen i
[__] hate zooming
but if it means i get to see you then so
be it you could just do so much talking
on the phone you know what i'm saying
oh it's great you look great man i gotta
tell you your skin looks great and you
you look fantastic man brother it's been
a re-haul
of my life since i got back here like
it's just been a
a complete haul from the reefer like i'm
cut down on reefer smoke 50
i only eat the edibles at night to go to
sleep now
uh the surgery went well you know as we
discussed on the phone
i got off the pain pills with no [__]
drama that that's big
you know i've been lifting i've been
working out and i just
just getting stronger every day brother
that's great man
that's great my next my neck's all good
you look great too man it's good to see
that you look [__] great
non-stop [__] i do five miles a day and
then some uh
yoga and and uh youtube
um like uh exercises
it's my gym now the youtube really
yeah i go to the gym you know the pt
keeps me busy
it's an hour and a half monday to
wednesday and friday and then i go to
the gym
opposite that i try to go two or three
days but this week it hit me a little
hard this week like by thursday
i didn't make pt on friday because i was
[__]
wiped the [__] out last week for some
reason
after i got off the pain meds i got off
the pain meds i think on sunday
and i was having headaches but by
thursday
like from working out all weekend and
the two pts
and lifting and tuesday and thursday i
think friday i just broke down man
like i i was supposed to go see sam
tripley friday night
i had plans with my [__] uh wife
already
and sadly you know i had uh some patreon
stuff to do
and i just wasn't i just couldn't get
myself to get out of the house that
night i took a you know i shower
i go you know i go out i take my rides i
got my friends in the neighborhood but
as far as going out and
you know i just don't have the [__]
uh whatever yet i'm not emotionally
there you know
yeah yeah i did i did a show last night
felt good i got two tonight
and uh it feels good to get on stage
it feels like when i first started you
know i get a little butterflies
i'm trying to remember the material the
new stuff and
it it is kind of a cool way to do comedy
because when you do it as much as we did
it
and then you don't do it you feel like
you got the feeling back again the feels
of like what it's like like oh i'm on
stage
you know that's such a weird thing you
know when i go down
on wednesday nights once i hit the stage
i'm having a good time i'm not lying to
you when i'm telling you i am having a
good time
but just the thought process of it
and getting dressed and going down there
that's the hard thing like during the
week
i'll ask myself on a tuesday night joey
get up go out take a ride
and it's like i can't even do that like
i've become such a family guy
at the house you know i have two friends
i grew up with
in north bergen that live close by i
mean two of them it's it's
it's it's amazing so they carry the
blunt of my load i'm either at one guy's
house
or the other guy's house i go over there
for an hour every night
when i was injured they came here every
night
we smoke a bowl outside we watch some tv
you know we're all in our 50s those two
guys are two years older than me
so but i hung out with them at concerts
and [__]
the one guy went to concerts with a lot
he's the one that gave me the
eight track with the sony maze the same
on it and uh
and the allman brothers live at the
fillmore
so now 30 years later we've reconnected
i see him a lot you know so
i'm uh writing on the book we got the
proposal down
the three chapters wow myself and erica
yeah we got the three chapters down
and you know it look inside you've been
like in a twilight zone place like
i'm not making any progress i say to
myself every week
but when i really look at it on sundays
i am making progress
you know we're doing a podcast or
writing a book so what i'm not writing
jokes
that's okay i've been writing jokes for
the last 30 [__] years
you know that's okay i've learned to
accept this new role
as suburbian dad like a suburban [__]
dad you know
so it's kind of fun but i do miss
you guys you know that's just the way
life
is i miss seeing you guys i mean it's
been a year
since i've been at the store and that's
like a
bittersweet in a way like one part of me
it makes me happy but the other part of
me makes me really sad that
my job of 22 years shut down you know
it's going to open up now
you know it'll be open by the end of the
month hopefully
i think so i think the game is over i
think whatever was going on now
people have had enough i think americans
have had enough
and americans are going wait a second i
got a 94
survival rate i'm going through all this
you know i knew people who wouldn't
leave their room never mind the house
during the podcast
during the pandemic now they're out
they're out
they finally came to the conclusion that
[__] it i'd rather die than be in a
bedroom
and you know a lot of people going
through mental health issues right now
a lot of people are frustrated
unemployment checks aren't getting there
you know it's just the world is in a
weird place but
we're still making strides you're doing
your patreon you've had the best
six months i've had i i've seen i mean i
want to congratulate you on
ac dc and you just had some [__] last
week
you had the guy [__] gary newman hear
him
[Music]
you know it just shows you that guys
like us were a little older
and we adapted bill burr adapted
every this teaches people how to adapt
and
we just didn't shut down we kept going i
shut down for one month because i was
moving
i shut down in august mid mid august we
did all the podcasts
but i shut down september you know and
just to evaluate myself
and thank god i kept in touch with mike
and fanny and they kept pushing me
let's go you got to do this you know and
i'm happy i did it because
if i would have waited till now i would
have been still [__] i would have been
more [__] up
do you know what i'm saying absolutely
yeah yeah because
you know it's funny how how loyal fans
can be but if you're
shut down for six months man out of
sight out of mind
they've moved on it's really wild you
know for me i don't consider them fans i
can
consider them family you know exactly
and you know i put it together in my
head
it took me 10 long years to understand
what i was doing with this podcast
what i was saying on here i was burying
my soul you know and
and it's uh
i think people need this right now i
think people want to know that
even the people they think that are
bulletproof
are not bulletproof we believe when we
get cut
you know i've said it for years we all
put our pants on one leg at a time
so with the joey's joint i took in a
different direction
obviously there's no pot smoking anymore
you know i only smoke for the music
section of the podcast
yeah i want to just you know i can't i'm
in the house with my daughter i got to
respect her and
what's going on that's why my pot smoke
consumption
has gone down i mean i've cut it in half
wow
it's amazing the edibles
i haven't done an edible in the daytime
i don't know how long it's been
you could probably buy a second house
with the cut back that you did
you got a rental going it's crazy how
i uh my appetite's coming back finally
for a long time i lost my appetite
after the surgery [__] last night i
think i got i think i took the
i took the edible to go i was tired so i
said let me make my [__] little tea
let me put my sleeping edible in there
oh my god
i laid down and the [__] hunger woke
me up i had to [__]
go eat some cheese enchiladas my wife
made yesterday or the day before
i just put them down so i'm [__]
happy that
you know i got my appetite back
i wasn't eating at night no more like
that stopped
that stopped like in august me in the
night and
it's amazing how much my life changed
and i knew i knew in april that
a lot of lives people were going to
change careers
people going to look at their lives and
go [__] this i've been doing it wrong
all along
for me i i hadn't done anything wrong
you know the reefer and stuff
obviously you know when you're doing 2
000 milligrams a [__] day
you're gonna look like uh a [__] bomb
hit you you know even though i was
taking care of myself but
i think what got lifted off me was i got
off the conveyor belt
yeah i got a hamster i got off the
ferris wheel
and that it took a long time to get
adjusted to that because
i'm a street guy like you we're hustlers
we don't stop we're like sharks
you know what uh you were in a band for
30 years then you became a comic
i've been a comic for 30 years mike just
got me a guitar
i'm gonna get my first lesson on monday
today today i get my first lesson what
am i talking about today i get my first
lesson
that's so great yes i tried the youtube
thing
i picked up a few things but i just want
to catch the basics from this guy
and then i got all of you guys to help
me i got guys on patreon sending me
tapes
mike's going to help me a little bit so
i guess i'm going to grow up to be the
next [__] mark
marin and play the guitar and uh
hopefully in a couple years you'll do it
ac dc reunion again when we're in our
60s and we could [__] bang it out
yeah and be like the stones junior and
[__]
joey up there malcolm malcolm diaz
michael diaz [__] yeah
it's funny i learned guitar um
on on a video called learn guitar on the
vcr
i bought it yeah i bought it on late
night tv
have you ever wanted to learn guitar now
it's easier than ever with learn guitar
on the vcr
so i got the tape and then i bought one
of those shitty
um small tvs with the built-in vcr and i
rented out a small little studio in
downtown san francisco
and i went there 10 hours a day like i
did comedy
and i popped that tape in and i just
would learn 10 hours a day
and by the end of the year i wrote a
record and had a record deal
it was crazy no [__] yeah and then i put
that record out man and toured all over
the place
no [__] that's how you got into all this
that's well i played music forever as a
singer
and i could play a little bit of guitar
but i was like i need to learn the
guitar inside and out so i can
write my own songs because i kept
hearing songs in my head
and i was only writing lyrics and melody
but i needed to write
music also so i said i'm taking a year
off
and i'm going to do this and [__] man it
was one of the best things i ever did
besides doing comedy you know i i
battled it the same way as doing comedy
i just dug deep into it
that's what you have to do you know when
you fall in love with something
so the first week i just looked at
youtube and picked up some pointers
and at night i just go back in the
office and now this week i had the
courage to put an album on
and just like instead of lip syncing
guitar sinking over it you know like
just [__] around
just listen man it keeps me uh it keeps
my mind fresh
i started reading again i i got to the
point dean where
i was trying to read like book like the
halford book
jimmy florentine gave me the half a book
do you know i read that whole book in
like four days and i can't tell you what
i read
oh isn't that weird i'm the same way
that happened to me with two [__]
books dean
not one two and i was so furious i go
i can't even even like people don't
understand like people call me or
contact me to do things
like i had an audition last week 11
pages good [__] luck
good [__] luck good luck i'm not
gonna i put
it was two scenes i put one scene up i'm
like i'm not gonna remember too [__]
there's no way there was a i mean it was
like 18 little [__] things
you can't read on tape with your glasses
on you look like a [__] jerk-off
so you got to know this [__] off book i
don't i i couldn't get it off book
there's no [__] way so i said [__] it
i'm going to start reading
books i've already read so i
i started with the man who led zeppelin
and now i'm back to the corporation
books that i've already read
and just to remind me of what i read and
it's been great that's helped me a lot
also just reading
comedy writing is [__] dead in my
world dean
i try to write a joke you know it's
[__] it was funny because the other
night
i was by myself in the back room and i
had pink floyd i just put on pink floyd
to wish you were here um and i was
playing wish you were here i was playing
on the
on the electric guitar and it sounded
more like wish you weren't here like i
was laughing about myself
i'm like that's the type of jokes i'm
writing like jokes that goof on me you
know what i'm saying like
jesus christ if anybody heard this they
wish they wouldn't be here
so it's like little things like that
like little jokes like that yeah
but like a bit like bill burr does
i can't do that [__] anymore like i
can't even
i look at bits and i'm like i'm happy i
get on stage once a week
i'm happy i do it to give the girls a
breather
and to get me out you know because i
don't want to be at a restaurant or at a
bar hanging out
you know yeah so i haven't even been to
my hometown and maybe
since the new year it's march 8th
i haven't been to north bergen since
valentine's day and before that
it was like two weeks before the surgery
wow
that's a 55-minute drive for me i don't
even do that
so if i'm not even going to see my
friends up there it's like
i'm down here i'm surrounded by trees
and deer
i got everything i need down here
[__] great pizza
i got a soundstage if i got to tape the
uh
the commercials for rogan or for spotify
i could walk to that [__] studio
that's great so i've i'm just the last
six months it's just getting adjusted i
can't believe it's been six months since
i last saw you
i can't believe it i remember you pulled
up
you said hey you home i said yeah i'm
home and you pulled up
and you got out of the car and i was
like oh this guy's got cancer or
something like you never do that you
know like i need to talk to you
hey came over you i'm done i'm uh moving
to jersey
and i was like whoa i couldn't believe
it you know i was like
i knew it was something real because you
don't go hey you home i'm coming over
right now yeah you're like one of the
first persons i really told
you know like i always knew i was
leaving
uh when i came home to shoot the
sopranos was when
i really realized i belonged back here
it was just a matter
it was just going to be a matter of time
you know right
uh i wish i could tell you the pandemic
made me move
i was going to move anyway the pandemic
just
pushed us you know pushed a little
quicker
yeah i think the pandemic has done some
good stuff also
yes it makes us all realize oh wait a
minute
wait a minute there's more to life than
just [__] doing
one thing you know we're only here once
and if
if we would have died from the pandemic
it would have been like well man i never
you know like you i didn't learn guitar
or something and
i would have been okay if i died from
the pandemic because i started comedy
and i was like well i started something
new and i wasn't just working a dead-end
goddamn
job you know what i mean so i've been
like i'm fine like when i got ran over
on the motorcycle no regrets
so i think a lot of people wake up like
that you know like oh [__]
[Laughter]
right i want to do something do you
remember i told you i'm like dean i
can't believe you ride a motorcycle
you're going to get hit one day
and like a week later you got [__]
clocked i was like i felt so bad
i feel so [__] bad because l.a
listen i was nervous to ride a bicycle
in l.a yeah
yeah you have to assume they're that
[__] stupid you know
yeah with the bike lane i would go for
my bike rides at 7
30 in the morning during the pandemic
when there was nobody
and i got almost got hit by a car 10
[__] times
just going just going like 30 yards it
was a 30-yard stretch that i had a pedal
on the street
and i would always get hit all the
[__] times because that's where the
170 people got off the 170 there
oh by the way so it was like jesus
christ i'm gonna get killed on this
[__] thing and i told i want two
people about bicycles
and both of them got into an accident
like [__] two weeks later there was a
cuban girl at the y
that was from miami and me and my wife
before mercy was ever
born we used to go on date nights when i
first moved to north hollywood
we had that noho diner which is [__]
garbage
but at the time that's the best you got
to eat
so we would go to the y do yoga from 5
30 to 6 30 run to that [__] place the
no ho dinah we'd eat and then we'd shoot
up
to the house and watch whatever sons of
anarchy
and one day i saw her getting on a bike
with a helmet on
on a tuesday night at 6 30 i go
you ride a bike to sherman oaks and
she's like yeah
it's just like three miles i'll be home
in 15 minutes ago that's not the point
you're riding your bike outside in the
dark i'm scared to ride my bike in the
daytime this was way before i had my
bike
like i said this is before mercy was
born right about
two weeks later i see the girl in yoga
and she's got a cast on and she goes
like hey just came by to tell you you're
a psychic
i was riding my bike and the guy opened
this door and didn't see me
she had to get her tooth front teeth
replaced oh [__] plastic surgery on
above her eye she flew off the [__]
over the
bars and [__] you know it's crazy riding
your bike in l.a that's just a [__]
night marriage
i would see i was [__] 35 years on
that bike and i was just
uh i was addicted to it man i just
there was it's a rush man of just
splitting this is a rush
getting into the next spot like holy
[__] okay i'm gonna do the store
now i'm gonna boogie up the bray improv
and then i'm gonna boogie over to the
irvine improv man i'm doing three spots
just no
i was funny i did san diego last week i
headlined out there it was great four
shows sold out man
and aisles i thought about was i was
driving home saturday night
after the late show and i was like i
used to ride a motorcycle
back from la jolla comedy store in the
cold and fog and dark
all the way back after the spots at the
store
crazy no matter how you know when it's
60 degrees on a bike
you're [__] cold freezing even when
it's 50 degrees you're [__] cold you
got all the hoods on and the [__]
you know i remember as a kid riding a
motorcycle in jersey and it's
i don't care if it's 60 degrees out and
warm when you're riding at night and the
sun goes down it's [__] cold out
there in those [__] swamps
you know it gets it's a lot colder than
what people [__] think so
i'm happy you got rid of that motorcycle
when you told me you got rid of it i was
like thank
[__] god he got rid of that goddamn
thing because
it's so good now i'm just in the toyota
4runner right
i got the the heat on i got the xm radio
on
and i'm just like listening to killer
music i'm like this is the way
man you know just chilling
speaking about music man i saw you
tweeting on saturday
uh the rhino records
uh released black sabbath mob rules and
black sabbath
heaven and hell they sent me both copies
i want to give a shout out because it's
rhino records metal
madness month or whatever over
uh rhino records i made a video for them
last week thanking them
for all the albums they sent me they
sent me like the volume four
and they sent me uh heaven and hell
and uh mob rules and i i gotta tell you
something man
when you look at hindsight 2020 you know
they say hindsight whatever the [__]
it's so weird because you came on the
podcast maybe five years ago
and you turned me on to humanize your
eye
which is the when d.o came back and did
the album with sabbath
and i went home and i listened to it and
i thought it was brilliant
you know my rules came out as i was
going into my
heavy criminal period that's when the
mob rules came out
so i really wasn't into that mob rules
too much heaven and hell was a life
changer for me
you retweeted them last saturday you
know because they're releasing this week
right when i got the copies i gave my
mob rules to jimmy florentine because i
already had
a copy of mob rules but it made me
listen to heaven and hell again
and it made me listen to mob rules again
and when i heard that sign of the
southern cross
whatever the name of it off mob rules
i'm like yeah [__] dean delray
reminded me of like i thought about you
i was like
and that's why i'm booking the podcast
from now on when i think of people for
some reason
i'm just going to call them up and go i
want you on the podcast man because
i like last week i was watching the
sopranos
and i'm like enough is enough i got to
get david chase to do a zoom with me
you know oh did he do it no we're gonna
do it before the movie comes out
hopefully
i could take him down to austin and do
the rogan experience
and then he could do like a 30 minute
zoom with me
for the joint you know but it's like
when i think of people now
i wanna like you know i'll call you 11
o'clock at night which is eight o'clock
your time
of course my wife my wife goes to bed at
[__] eight o'clock
nine o'clock and i'm left with my dick
in my hand
so i got two options i could [__]
watch tv
or i could listen to music and now i can
play the guitar
yeah or write and i've even started
reading at night before i go to bed like
i just turned the tv off
but the one night i called you because
i listened to the mob rules and i was
like man did i waste my time with drugs
this was such a great album like i just
you know by the time
listen by the time mob rules came out um
[Music]
for those for those about to rock
yep um there was a couple of albums that
the one with london with uh ted nugent
where he did
uh duango tango oh yeah you know all
those albums were my goodbye to music
like i wasn't into music
that was my end of going to concerts it
was nothing but guns
and [__] cocaine after that like that
was
there was no period for music when i
moved to colorado in 83
i got into music but i got into music
that i hadn't gotten into before
like i got you know i got i started
listening to the eagles and the grateful
dead and you know uh
the nitty-gritty dirt band and [__] like
that
things that i hadn't listened to before
but i was so stuck
on sabbath you know i had put so much
time into sabbath and i was like i gotta
move on i gotta figure something out
but by you turning me on to d.o
and me going home at night and smoking
dope and doing edibles and listen to
deal
you kind of brought me back in a way and
i
didn't see that then but now
that i opened up i have it in her hell
and i turned it back on
by you turning me on to this is really
weird because
our lives are narrated by music you know
when we hear a certain song it takes us
back to a certain time period in our
lives
you know that's what's great about
sirius
that they got the 70s on 70 they got the
80s they got the 90s
they got the 50s they got the 60s you
could listen to all this music
and when i'm driving i'll just keep
switching serious until i find the song
i like and i'll
run with the genre whatever it is but
it's so weird how heaven and hell
brought me back
by you opening me up to that it brought
me back to thinking about new jersey
thinking about concerts again thinking
about my friends like i hadn't thought
i hadn't had those thoughts because
comedy had consumed my life
and now i look at how comedy can i mean
comedy consumed my life so much
all right i'm a fat [__] by nature but
not really if you look at the pictures
of me as a child i was always a bony
[__]
but comedy took me so deep that i i even
stopped caring about my
like i took showers but i stopped caring
about my health like that's how much i
was into comedy
when you're doing comedy the way you're
supposed to do it you're not supposed to
be healthy if you really think about it
you're out all night you're drinking you
know
some of us do drugs some of us don't you
know you're eating shitty
you're eating shitty in the bars you
know it's just the first 10 years of
comedy is like this [__]
diving into the abyss you know for some
of us
you got a guy like rogan that always
kept his health up
you know uh bill burr had to stop
drinking over the years
you know we all we all learn while
you're doing comedy what doesn't work
because
you learn more about yourself you're
unveiled you know you're opening up one
of those [__] artichokes you know
so you see what i was i was telling
somebody that day that
there's no more fiends in comedy no
no when i got into comedy people weren't
showing up in gigs
people were getting high people were
doing blow there's nobody doing coke and
comedy no more there's no drugs in
comedy
there's no sam kennison's anymore
nothing like that
no no it's business man and and you know
you can't be all [__] up on that patio
at the store because there's going to be
like three agents a casting
agent a a guy that's got a movie for you
and if you they you know if they come up
and
talk to you and you're all like they'll
be like oh whoa
okay yeah we'll give you a ring you know
and and i know you're saying
you're saying that to me and i i know i
lost
a thousand jobs and a thousand
relationships because
i would never get coked up at the store
like before the show
but after i went on stage it was every
man for himself it's an open [__] bar
yeah i don't have to you know you've
seen it you you i don't know yeah you
lived it
also you saw what it was like up there
you know that
it's very easy to go up there and get
messed up with drugs and drinking
you know i got caught up with comedy so
much that i even
i didn't turn my back on music i just
it had felt like been there done that
but it was music that brought me back by
listening to that music
that that deo stuff and all that i start
and let me tell you something
i wanted heaven and hell to fail so bad
you know i mean you know i wanted heaven
and hell the [__]
i wanted to hate heaven and hell so much
but i ended up falling in love with the
album
at that age like and now i look back at
the courage that it took i remember i
had
uh ronnie james dio's wife on
and i told her wendy i told her the
truth i go everybody around me wanted
that album to fail
you know you were dissing ozzy but as a
music enthusiast that showed you
how to be a real man in a way how to go
wow
even though i wanted this to fail this
is a great [__] album
and i'm gonna pay attention to it you
know
it's interesting and when you listen to
them
it's uh it's it's black sabbath it's
bill ward on heaven hell
and it's tony iomie and geezer butler
it's the same three guys
but when dia was in the band they seem
to play
more violence uh tony naomi plays
way way more violent lead guitar
his tone is different and and their
their tempos are different and
everything it's just more of this
punch in the face like when you open up
with neon nights you're like
whoa this is uh this is violent music
as far as the uh performance uh compared
to say
some of the classic sabbath which is
kind of a little sleepy and droney you
know
down that kind of stuff
mastery ish
which is a great album to an album like
you know uh children of the sea let's
take that song for example
that's a very unclassic classic
sabbath song right it's unclassically
classic sabbath and
there's a certain beauty to it it's a
great little ballad
you know i love i love changes i love
them going through changes great balance
you know ozzy did some great ballads
with black sabbath but
i think children just to see dio [__]
it up if you want to call it ballad
to me it's it's a ballad to some people
might be listening to this they might go
jordan we don't know what the [__]
you're talking about that's not a ballad
it's a ballad to me
um it's a haunting ballad it's a
haunting [__] ballad
when i [__] when i put that album
back on it just
it took me right back there this week
and
it just let me know that it was you
that brought music back into my life and
i wanted to thank you like you really
opened my eyes to i i remember having
bert on like in 2015
and him and i did a podcast about guns
and roses
i had gotten so many emails from 20 year
olds
that said they had never even heard of
guns and roses it [__] infuriated me
yeah it infuriated me that
uh we all that kids knew were you know
welcome to the jungle they didn't get to
see the videos for november rain and all
you know
which are [__] masterpiece videos
not only were their masterpiece record
guns and roses learned to master the
video
sweet child of mine is a great [__]
video they really
you know it's weird to know that our
friend uh gene kirkland
was on that video shoot as a young
photographer you know
dead videos and it blew me away like i
that podcast would burn
and the response i got it wasn't like
thank you for being funny no no no no
thank you for opening our eyes to this
[__] and all of a sudden like
three years later i'm not saying because
of me i'm just saying
like three years later they were the
first band to break a billion views
uh crazy i think it's november rain did
break yeah
a billion views like three or four years
later after our podcast
again i'm not saying this because we did
the podcast
but it even made me go home and listen
to guns and roses it made me go home
you know on patreon i just recently
started playing the pretenders
now what the f why the [__] do you peg
me as a pretenders fan
so music brought me back to to being
coco diaz you know not a comic
just a human being again like it brought
me back to [__] coco diaz again
when i stopped playing music it made me
start to love it again so when you're so
deep into music you're just kind of
blinders on and you're just recording
and making music
and and then when i got out of it and
that's why i started at the comedy store
because it was you know the building's
painted black it's on sunset strip it's
a hundred percent rock and roll that
place
it goes way back with kenison and dice
and all the rock in there
and all the rockers hanging out there
and i was like i'm gonna start here
and then they'd play rock on the patio
and i was just like
man i love music again like more than
ever
you know because i was out of it and i
could
just enjoy it without feeling a slight
competitive uh thing when you're playing
music you know like ah they put out a
[__] good record god damn it i gotta
get better you know that whole thing it
was wild now i could just listen to it
as a full fan it's funny because
i always admired the dj
when i was a kid i always thought about
djing like not in a disco you know
scratching and [__] just
just the i love the idea of turning
people
on to to music they hadn't heard before
with a story you know i'm not in love
with stand-up anymore right now
for some reason i'm just at a blah state
with stand-up right now
but the last this pandemic has made me
fall in love
we fall in love with music i'm happy
mike got me the guitar
as a gift because now it's an extension
but it also i don't know how to describe
it like
it just removed a lot of cobwebs for me
music during this time
to settle me a little more like i even
put on
i put on an album that i haven't
listened to in 40 years i put onto
the good rats now i forget the name of
the album you know
and i was like wow i can't believe i
used our birth comes to us all
oh by the good rats the good rats were
banned out of long island when i was a
kid
and they had a couple good songs i think
they opened up for somebody at the
garden they made good
you know they didn't hit the mecca of it
but i've even done things like that i've
listened to the kinks
silly lloyd heroes you know uh
uh [__] the one with uh lola v
meets superman you know all these albums
i've been listening to all these older
type albums
to let me know who the [__] i was
growing up
and it's done a [__] great job
without a psychiatrist
you know i didn't have to go online and
talk to a psychiatrist or seek a
religion or whatever
i mean my relationships have gotten
stronger with my wife and my child
during this
uh pandemic but what i enjoy the most
right now
more than stand up is doing the album of
the week
because that means that i come down here
after dinner like
wednesday and i [__] smoke a bone
and i go in that room i lock the door i
put my feet up on the couch
and i get to listen to an album like
when i was like 15 without a worry in
the world
you know like when you're when you're 25
and you listen to an album it sounds
different
than it did when you were 15 because now
you got a life
you're in college you just graduated
college you're at a law firm you're this
you're that
so you forget all the [__] you know you
forget it
i didn't this is what brought me back
was listening to
that old music again i feel 100 better
than i did in los angeles uh
i'm off the ferris wheel like i'm off
the [__] ride
i could do comedy on my terms you know
like that i don't know if that
but this has made me fall in love that
that preparing for album of the week
is my favorite [__] thing that i do
now yeah because i could do an album of
the day if i wanted to
yeah i would do an album of the day and
sit there with them
and then it could be eight hours like it
could be joint after joint like if i had
a job where you go listen
we want you to present a [__] album
every day
just smoke weed you got four hours to
kill i could fill that
because i could break down every song we
could go over the lyrics
we could see where they recorded the
album at you know i love all
that [__] i love that [__] too that's
right
that's i wanted to be on siriusxm and
just do that [__] you know like
present new music like here's marcus
king man
and this is why i like him and this is
where i saw him and this is where he
his sound comes from and that breakdown
that kind of stuff
rival sons new bands that i'm constantly
finding so
people are that say there's no good
music anymore i could just be like
you're wrong
listen to my show every day at two
o'clock i'm gonna give you three bands
you know yeah no no i like it from that
perspective but since i'm not on top of
the new bands
yeah this you know listen right now the
people watching and listening to this
podcast
i gotta say that maybe ten percent of 50
year olds
we got maybe 30 percent of 40 or 50s
we got like another 20 in their 30s but
everybody else
is in their 20s and late teens
and maybe their father didn't listen to
sabbath or the stones or leonard skynyrd
or
you know i just listened to frank marino
and mahogany rush live so so great
1978. that you know
just the thought of listening to that
album i almost called you at one in the
morning and said
you know what happened with frank
mourinho that was a
that was like that could have happened
that happens with comics
that's a great cop you know the kid who
passed away a couple weeks ago eric
god rest his soul he was a great comic
that kid
you know he just had other demons that
were haunting him
the reason why people didn't hear about
him before that was because he fell
through the cracks
and that happens with a lot of bands
today like you like [__] that was a
great band
but they didn't tesla oh yeah tesla's
got 20 [__] great songs
yeah but they didn't get to the heights
of judas priest or
iron maiden or you know sabbath
but yeah tesla's a good band y and t
there's a lot of great white tee there's
a lot of great bands that
uh just start through the holes you
don't you don't and and
with comics that happens also they were
great i'm
finally [__] excited that holtzman
came out of his coma
after 20 years that the world could see
who the [__] brian holtzman is he
finally moved to austin
he's down there with brian and tony
hinchcliffe and he's being a comic
that guy is one of the funniest guys
walking today
but the world never got to see him
because holtzman always needed a [__]
job
funniest guy walking off the cuff funny
as [__] he's a killer
he's a killer killer so you know like
i'm excited like last week i was like
what the [__]
brian holtz was at the store for 22
years he didn't want to do comedy
now he wants to do comedy this is what
the pandemic did to people
and for a guy like me who couldn't even
think about not doing like
dog if you know that monday night that i
wouldn't go to the store
when they would have like killed tony
yeah i'll be doing
i'd be doing a podcast and i'll tell you
what
between me and you as men i was
embarrassed i wasn't there
yeah like the way i lived my life you're
supposed to stand up every [__] night
the only reason why i gave myself a pass
on those nights on mondays and
wednesdays
was because i was doing a podcast it's a
form of entertainment
but if i wasn't doing a podcast i'd
still have to be out i would beat myself
up
to be out that's who i am and when
you're a comic that's what you need to
be
that's what and now i look at myself
i don't even i look outside that back
patio some nights
and i go out there and i smoke a number
in the cold
and i and i smoke a half a number to be
honest with you
i put it away for the next day i don't
even smoke the whole [__] number
but that just goes to show you that how
people have changed during this pandemic
like holtzman went from wanting a day
job he saw himself on that documentary
on the comedy store and he goes [__]
this
i'm gonna go do [__] comedy for
[__] time i'm wasting my [__] life
being a [__] dog catcher whatever the
[__] he's doing so i hope now people get
to
[__] witness the brilliance that's
brian holtzman
yeah he's he's great man i had him on
the podcast a few months ago and
i mean i remember when i started i'd
have to kind of follow him
uh and man it was the
it was the greatest lesson ever because
it was just like
it it was almost impossible if you could
just get one laugh you're like all right
i kind of i i
got out of there as a tie because he
would just disintegrate the room
he would disintegrate the room yeah and
it taught me
to learn how to follow people like him
or rick
ingram or a brodie that are completely
outside the box different
uh you know uh rhythms and cadence and
uh
volumes and you know loud or whatever
organic you know just
winging it all that kind of stuff of
like oh i gotta be
more in the moment and free
and [__] it man address it if you're
bombing up there after holtzman you're
like yeah you come up here and try to go
on after holtzman that kind of [__] and
it started to work and i figured it out
i was like all right i got this you know
but it's been a long time what killed me
the most about holtzman was
watching him was not i wouldn't watch
holtzman
i'd watch the audience reaction i would
just sit in the back i wouldn't sit in
mitzi's chair
i'd sit in that other chair across from
the bathroom right if you come out of
the bathroom there's a chair
yeah that's a good one i like that
because the two i mean yeah at midnight
there would be nobody in that [__]
when houlton would go up it would be
like me
holtzman and somebody else so we
wouldn't even have a [__]
you know there would be eight people in
there 10 people 12 people
so i would go watch their faces after
holtzman it would always turn down the
four
like he would always walk four people
like i would go holtzman please
[__] don't walk those four because we
they the comedy store in those days
needed four people to do a show
yeah and there were many nights that
that's all we had in that [__]
was four [__] people so
you know it would get to like 22.
paul mooney would go up he would get off
it would get to like 12.
so now i had [__] eight people left
that i had to pray for that [__]
horseman wasn't gonna walk
and he used to have a bit that he had a
kid that was gay and he would take his
son to the baseball games to blow off
he would take him to trucker stops to
blow truckers and [__] because
because his son was gay and he wasn't
when he was a baby he would take him to
baseball games
and just take his dick out and feed him
at baseball games and [__]
and i would watch people's faces and
they would lose it
that was an education that was an
education itself
so i'd be sitting there you know i'm
cheering for the [__] to do well
but at the other hand i'm cheering for
[__] these eight people to stay
because without them i'm not gonna get
my 15 and
[__] in those days i needed those
[__] 15
badly hell yeah so i would watch
holtzman go
please do have a great show i want to
laugh
but don't do that [__] you take your
kid to the baseball games and you suck
your dick
when he's hungry bit because people get
[__] you know
people just get [__] annoyed and they
walk out i saw people storm out of there
that were gay you know when he would say
that joke
but i mean that that's the way it was
you had to go up there follow holtzman
to six people yeah there'd be six
[__] people in the [__] audience
and i'd go jesus christ so now i'm doing
shows for i think
it's they raised it to 35 new jersey so
i think i got like 40 something people
in there
every wednesday they'll probably raise
it up
towards the end of the month i think by
june
i was looking at the schedule for the
concerts around here
they're [__] straight their full boat
jack steely dan
the third of july over at pnc whatever
so i don't i don't know what they're
gonna do i don't know what the seating
arrangements are
but they're going for it so i'm off to
des moines iowa
next weekend or this week this weekend
yeah my first road dates in one year my
first plane ride
everything i'm going to t he's in des
moines
and i'm going to go do three shows one
friday to saturday and i'm ready man
i feel i'm writing some of the best
material in my
11 year career 10 and a half years now
and i feel i'm uh
i i know from the pandemic i love this
more than
anything and comedy saved me actually
because if i was just
selling motorcycles during the pandemic
like i was
i've been done i would have been done i
would have no money
i would have really no friends a couple
friends that you know have
kids and i'd see from work but i'd be
done
so comedy when i look at it and also
getting that diabetes when i did and
beating it
prepared me not to die for the [__]
pandemic because you know i got
coveted back in march i would have been
[__] dead
with with diabetes so everything's kind
of uh
uh it's i i really believe this joey
i've said this many times i feel like
your life map is laid out for you
when you're born i kind of feel like
that because here i am like man some
somebody's looking out for me because
i'm uh i was doing comedy
and thank god i was in the patreon and
the podcast i do the podcast 10 years
so without that i would be just you know
this is crazy to think about you know uh
i'm very happy that
i felt i always wanted to tell you that
i always felt bad leaving you there like
i felt really bad you know like i'm like
he's like he's become like my brother
over the years you know i was happy to
see
lee leave and steve simone leave you
know
i didn't want to feel like a quitter you
know at first that's what i felt like
i'm a quitter for leaving
but i wasn't leaving because of me i was
leaving for my daughter
you know i get it right now my daughter
is at a play date
you know or she's in school but i you
know on [__] saturdays and sundays
now
there's no more daughter in the house
those days are done
like her and my wife have [__] lives
here
yeah tripoli performed on friday and
saturday
in uh in uh at the comedy dojo
you know i was gonna go thursday night
with jimmy but his son
had a a game on thursday night
and then friday night my wife went out
you know my wife has friends here i mean
you know she goes out once a week
and then saturday night i had you know
[__] to do
we went to a friend's house and then by
the time i got back i was
it was too late to drive to tripolis and
we have that thing on
saturday nights as a family we watch the
honeymooners at 9 30.
i got to watch it all in the family at
nine uh
the honeymooners and then they go to
sleep and
me and my wife watch the honeymooners at
11. so it's like
you know man uh doug stanhope said it
best last week
that he is the first time since he was
that he slept in his bed for a year yeah
yeah you know i i was like everybody
else
i gotta be honest with you when the
pandemic first hit
i was concerned and worried but then
as it went on i got happy because
i needed to break my spirit my soul
i had been going [__] straight since
1970 [__] nine
man yeah i've been going straight
you know i i have been out every night
since 1979 when my mother died
and i lived with a family it was hard to
stay in a house
at night with a family that wasn't yours
you know
even though i loved them and i cared for
them and they cared for me
just the thought of being in the room
was like being in prison at the age of
16.
so i've been out every night since 1979.
so you know what sam it's it's been a
great [__] year
it's been i had my ups and downs since
the pandemic started you know when the
pandemic started
i got caught up with the [__] uh with
the [__] pills
and you know my anxiety went off
[__] killed her and then little by
little you know i went through all these
things i remember
eating i told my wife that
up until i think september 1st
i had a [__] knock myself out every
night to sleep
and when i mean knock myself out i mean
that
i had built a tolerance that only heroin
could probably
conquer i could do i could do
i was eating five of those capsules and
one of them
will kill you one of those [__]
hashtabs
yeah they'll kill you 100 milligrams i
was eating five or six hundred
two hundred milligrams you know
yeah i was [__] killing my brazzer
pam whatever that [__] [__] is those
footballs
i was eating four or five of those
things a night
i had a collection of them my doctor
kept prescribing to me
since like 2008 and i never took them
yeah i just put all the jars together i
had like 20 jars of these pills
so every time express grip would send
them i would have a jar of those [__]
footballs and i just
probably my whole life was turning on
world news tonight
and playing [__] uh you know stop the
anxiety
so once i think i got settled
september 1st once i moved i went to a
party
and i seen all these people without
masks and i'm like [__] it
i'm gonna [__] die but i can't keep
living loud i'm living and
here we are today i'm a lot better what
do you feel now
since it's been what two months since oh
you had covered
this february or last year i had it last
march at the beginning early covet
okay and how do you feel now do any
after effects or anything
i feel great it was like three months i
was just completely like uh
sluggish if i was working out i was kind
of burnt
and i would it would come and go just
kind of this weird flammy [__] in my
throat i never had the cough
but i had the fever that would you would
want to shoot yourself with a bullet
four days of this gnarly fever
and then um i would just it was weird it
took about three months for me to kind
of get back to like oh i'm finally
normal again um i was just burnt
all the time so it could have been also
uh
anxiety and stress and depression
with a combo of detoxing from the um
from the covid and i also had a weird
thing that nobody seems to know what it
was but
my nose kind of blew up
like a bukowski day drinking nose
and just ooze out like an oil all day
like my
nose was just greasy with big old
pores i don't know what the [__] that
had to be some
uh side effect that nobody's got but
dude
i remember i was doing an instagram live
and someone said man you need
sunblock your nose is [__] up and it
was
[__] up my nose i thought it was going
to be like that for life i was like my
nose is ruined
it was crazy
yeah i i don't know like the last
week i took two cove the test i got a
guy now that just
lets me come in for a flat price we
become friends because anytime i'm
you know i always try to take a test on
thursday you know i got mike i don't
want to give it to mike and then he has
kids and stuff like that
right you know i go over to florentines
and stuff but besides that i really
don't do much
i go to the gym and uh
nobody there has it they leave both
doors open
you know when i go do comedy on
wednesdays at uncle vinnie's
i'm not scared at all i don't feel it's
40 people
you know so i'm all right now i just uh
my life changed a lot that's all that
happened you know
my watson desires have changed a little
bit and
you know what i'll take the summer off
and uh i'll see where my head is at when
the soprano movie comes out when the
many saints comes out
yeah if i get a slight bug up my ass
i'll i'll do a little [__] touring
then
and but for right now i'm just gonna sit
tight and keep listening to records and
learn to play the [__] guitar
that's it and that's all my phone does
the best the best thing on the planet i
think the iphone
is the photo memory so the
you know weekly it'll pop up this photo
memory
and a lot of them are with you and i sit
down for a minute like i sent you that
vegas uh photo from last week you know
and i was born on the 28th that was our
last road date that was it
that was my last road date and march 2nd
was when i went to
march 3rd was my last date at the store
yeah and march 10th was the bond scott
tribute and 12th was my last date at the
store
but these photos come up of you and i
all over man over the years dude
over the years we have gone
and melted some faces man melted some
faces
and made people happy and that is
better than anything on the planet when
you just hear people go
i saw you and julia's punchline and
joey's flight was canceled because the
fog
and you headlined the one night and then
i was like who's this guy and you killed
and i went back the next night you and
joey craig
you know like all these stories i get
all the time from people and it's great
man and that vegas show was
we were both [__] powery man cause we
had been just doing comedy 24
7 man listen man you're uh
you were one of the things that were
keeping me alive
towards the end because i was very
devastated with people
and young comics and how they were
acting
and everybody was looking for something
you weren't looking for anything you
were doing the work
so it kept me alive i admired that
i admired you know you and steve simone
and there was a couple of you guys
carmen morales
that you didn't think i was watching
jesus trail
but i was watching you may not think i'm
watching but i'm watching
that's why i love when people reach out
and say hey i'm doing this this and this
if you were doing that that night
i'd be [__] hearing about you yeah i
don't i haven't heard about you
but i was hearing little murmurs about
dean delray
and i was hearing little murmurs about
kate quigley
jesus trejo and you know
these comics that weren't scared to put
their [__]
you know they didn't care about being a
doorman
you just saw them that they loved comedy
so much
that i had to [__] do something for
them and then you had these other
handful of people
that just wanted to be stars and didn't
want to do the work they just thought
oh joey'll put me on this podcast and
take me on the road and i'll be a
[__] star really
it doesn't happen that quickly you got
to earn your [__] stripes [__]
so as far as i was concerned
all these people were upsetting my
internal [__] organs with their
[__] gimme gimme gimme
but i'm looking at guys like you and
steve simone and
craig quigley and you know jesus trail
it was just like a special eight of yous
and you guys would inspire the [__] out
of me
because i would look at you and go
that's the behavior you know wow i'm
proud
that these guys are acting this way
because that's what you want
but then you had these other handful of
[__] clowns
that thought that you know doing comedy
twice a week
earned them a right to come on the
podcast or
[__] me taking them on the road or
you know i get these [__] emails from
people
i hate you you ruined my life by not
putting me on my podcast
how the [__] is my podcast gonna make
you a [__] star
do you see me on abc yeah do you see me
hanging out with denzel [__]
washington you dumb [__]
do you see me hanging out with [__]
you know i'm not a [__] star i'm just
a fat [__] felon
working doing what you should be this is
what you should be doing is working
but then on the other hand i had guys
like you
that were doing the work you got to
remember i know you
i saw you as a chubby guy at the haha
yeah when i first moved to north
hollywood yep and then
and then you just reinvented yourself
you made decisions for yourself i'm not
going there no more
i'm gonna go to the store these are my
friends you know
you [__] i saw what you were doing and
it impressed the [__] out of me in the
society that
everybody was just give me give me give
me give me give me
i want to be on a podcast i want a shout
out i want you to take me on the road i
was getting tapes from people sent to me
on youtube
email you know [__] emails from
people that i didn't know i'm
a messenger i want you to take me on the
road or
you're coming to cleveland can i open
for you who the [__] are you
yeah i don't know you but i know that
dean delray did three [__] spots last
night
and he rode a bicycle to his last one
you know he went home put away his car
and drove a bike up to the [__] last
one
i know that [__] kate quigley's
taking bikini pictures and showing her
tits
but i also know that she's [__] out
there every night
you know i'm looking at you know all
these guys that were doing [__] great
work
you know crystal johnson just all these
comments you know look at [__]
and i never got her on the podcast
because she always worked
punky now she's upset and i [__] live
you know
yeah i was watching all these people
busting their hump
at the comedy store all these young kids
and i'm white and these [__] other
people
and every other state sending me oh can
i come on your podcast
they thought that by just going on a
podcast it was going to change their
life
and they had no idea of what goes into
this [__] career
they have no idea what goes into this
life
if you want to be a plumber or an
electrician a writer
[__] i'm learning now how to be a writer
after all these [__] years
30 years in the business and i'm
learning now how to write [__]
sentences and paragraphs and whatever
it took that [__] long i'm not a
writer i'm a comedian
i'm supposed to make you laugh yep
but that's why i got so close with you
because you inspired the [__] out of me
everybody else is bringing me the [__]
down everybody else is a [__] downer
you know everybody wants to go to heaven
but nobody wanted to die
and here i see you digging [__] holes
every week like me we were you know
we were out there every [__] night so
you always have a place a special place
in my heart
[__] the iphone with the [__]
memories those memories are in my heart
and in my soul
man same here and i'm happy you turned
me back on to d.o
sabbath and i'm happy that rhino records
is having heavy metal
month whatever the [__] they're doing
over there so if you're looking for some
reissues
and you're looking for the new uh heaven
and hell
it comes with great stuff the mob rules
comes with great stuff
comes with great stuff they're doing a
great job with those sabbath albums so
i'm impressed as [__] so as long as
you're doing well
and uh you promise me i'll see you
within the next year
we'll go together i'm gonna see you
before you know it man i'm going to be
in
jersey and i'm going to come see you and
we're going to go eat some shitty food
together
that's not good for us well let's
do all this some [__] great food in
this [__] neighborhood
i'm ready i got a chinese i got a
chinese place two minutes from my
[__] door
oh that they are you know i hate string
beans right
oh yeah i hate [__] string beans they
make a spicy garlic beef with string
beans
i'm eating this i'm i'm eating the
[__] string beans that's why i look
better because i'm finally eating my
string beans so
put that in your [__] piping smoking
[__]
dean delray thank you for coming on a
monday morning buddy
candles buddy
i tell everybody to check out my new
podcast the grail
uh it's out every thursday i got a
second podcast now the grail where i
interviewed all these
yeah make cool [__] like stereos and
guitars and amps and
you know architectures and uh
everything you know cars it's it's all
kinds of cool people man and they're out
there doing it
big time you still got your patreon oh
yeah
patreon yeah
patreon.com del rey and i i do a zoom
fest every weekend with all the people
that sign up so i do a
zoom hangout with all the patreoners
you're [__] beautiful and you still
got cbd lion
cbd lion from life man those guys
saved my life man and i i owe you
the world for that and cbdlion.com use a
code dean
use code joey a church [__] we
got cbd lion today so it's great
i love you buddy thank you very very
much for coming on and uh
i don't have to tell you to stay in
touch we talk every other day anyway so
yeah
thank you for coming on a monday morning
to uncle joey's joint [__] stay
black
i love all your fans man they're for
their family the church
people and now the joey's joint just
fabulous people man
fabulous i love you guys i love you dean
stay black all right buddy
all right have a good weekend you got it
stay everybody
bye what'd you think dean with a [__]
like i told you
two [__] uh two [__] mohawks
on a monday and a week two [__] for
ten years i did interviews i didn't
interview
nobody with a mohawk then two mondays in
a row i got uh doug stanhope last monday
and now this monday dean it was great to
talk to you dean it was great to talk to
him i mean uh
like you guys heard we had become close
a lot closer than what you guys thought
um as soon as i played that album last
week
i immediately thought of him i even i
call dean almost every night
late night i check in with him but last
week it hit me a little harder because
he was the one that introduced me to dio
again with humanizer like he reminded me
the strength of dio so uh i hope you
guys enjoyed our little monday morning
[__] chat
and that's it and that's that man it's
uh business as usual
i'll be at vinnie's on wednesday i think
uh the last
two dates there's still some tickets
left if you want to check in if you're
in the jersey area
my patreon's still alive and kicking uh
the album of the week was great i got a
little heat because last week
uh my friends go out to california he
goes out for business
he works for a record label and he goes
out every two or three weeks and he
stops my urban trees
and he brought me back a [__]
surprise a [__]
it's this uh uh what's in the capsules
the abx capitals
only it comes in a [__] syringe i
wish i showed it to you
so i did a video on the patreon last
week it comes with a needle and
everything
so i made a video of me like [__]
shooting heroin i
i opened up the video by saying that i'm
a heroin junkie
i didn't want nobody to know and i
[__] so many people hit me up and go
that [__] video was classic i thought
you were really on heroin people were
[__] dying so
patreon still alive and kicking three
five and ten dollars whatever you want
go over there
and see and uh we're here for free every
monday and wednesday
so i love you guys thank you very much
for watching and enjoying dean delray
and me
have a great week and now for a word
from our sponsors all right
i want to thank you [__] for
enjoying dean del rey i want to thank
dean delray
for coming on zuma it was great it was
beautiful it was great to see him with
his [__] mohawk
two mondays in a row i got a guy with a
[__] mohawk what are the [__]
chances
i love you [__] but before i go
the joint is brought to you by
blue chew like i told you [__]
little bird of happiness the blue bird
of happiness came to me this morning
when i woke up
and whispered in my ears tell your
people for harder and stronger [__]
erections
get blue chew listen combat all forms of
ed get your dick in tip top magoo even
if you don't have a form of vd
you always want to be prepared you want
to give them dick that
they'll be remembered you by yeah mike
came over and gave me some dick that'll
never happen again
i couldn't walk for [__] three days i
couldn't drink water
my nose was leaking that's the dick you
want to give anybody can sling dick
but if you want to give a good dick blue
chew is in the [__] house
same acting active ingredients as viagra
and cialis at a fraction of the [__]
cost
this ain't no snake dust this ain't no
hummus powder
this is blue chewer an online
prescription service
no visits to the doctor no awkward
conversations
no waiting online at the pharmacy this
is
science the process is simple you sign
up at bluetooth.com
you talk to one of the licensed medical
providers once you're approved
you receive your prescription within
days it's ship ripe to your door
not in a creepy [__] envelope with a
dick on it but nothing like that the
mailman don't know dick nobody knows
dick just you
blue chew tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped directly
way cheaper than a pharmacy so i got a
special for you for today
for monday uncle joey ain't gonna show
up on a [__] monday with nothing
you get blue chew for free try it for
free use promo code joey go to
bluetooth.com
press and code joey and just pay five
dollars for shipping
that's it it's that easy that's
bluetooth.com
promo code joey till you receive your
first month for free give it a shot
five [__] dollars take a chance
columbus did and as always i want to
thank bluechu
for sponsoring the joint the joint is
also brought to you by
oh [__] it's time to make a little
[__] doll
draftkings draftkings sportsbook
i am having such a great time with them
listen you guys
know that before i moved to jersey i
think i put [__]
three bets in those whole eight years
this [__] year this this football
season i've been putting 20s here 30s
here
you [__] play around with the boosts
it's not just for sports
they have an online casino also i love
draftkings
and this month it's ally oop [__]
it's march
that means it's time for the biggest
college basketball tournament
of the [__] year and for to celebrate
draftkings is going [__] completely
bananas
you bet four dollars an underdog if they
win
you you win 256 dollars
did you hear me four dollars on an
underdog if they win
you're up 256 dollars that's [__]
that takes balls that's why i'm with
draftkings
that's why i use draftkings that's why i
love draftkings
it takes four bucks to get a shot at
winning 256 dollars
the bank is open [__] if anyone knows
about betting on an underdog it's me
it's your uncle joey look at me now i'm
a [__] underdog
there's no better way to put your
college basketball knowledge to the test
than to put your money on a [__]
where your mouth is with draftkings
sports books
college ball ain't for you that's okay
draftking has great odds and promotions
on golf hockey
nba [__] ufc mma
bellator whatever they got it draftkings
is america's top rated sportsbook app
plain and simple it's safe secure
reliable
withdraw your money when you want it's
your [__] money
now who's better than draftkings nobody
who's better than you [__] nobody
that's why download the top-rated
draftking sportsbook app
now today let's get this [__]
tournament started
use promo code joy when you sign up to
turn
four dollars listen to me four [__]
dollars
into 256 dollars if the underdog of your
choosing
pulls off the upset that's code joey to
turn
four dollars into 256 [__] dollars
and it's a limited time only and it's a
draftking sports book
today right now i want you to go to
draftkingsportsbook
right now and download the [__] app
right now
and tell them uncle joey sent you but
use promo code joy when you sign up to
turn four dollars
into 256 dollars [__] my [__] patreon
[__] the three dollars go put the four
dollars on a [__] underdog
and win 256
okay now here's the part the lawyers
make me say you got to be 21 or older
if you're [__] not if you're 20 go go
do something that 20 year olds do
go [__] smoke a cigarette and get
dizzy or something like that new jersey
indiana
pa only tennessee new customers only
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details you got a gaming
problem
call 1-800 gambler when indiana called
1-809
with it but if you don't and if you're
[__] solid
and if you're emotionally [__]
correct download
the draftking sportsbook app and tell
them i [__] sent you
and it's time to make some [__] money
you understand me i'm not talking about
i'm not going to make you a millionaire
but it's fun it's better than just
sitting there like a [__] dunce
you're gonna watch the fight the game
the tournament the golf [__] game
anyway right or wrong download the
draftking sportsbook app now
and press in joey and i'm gonna [__]
turn four dollars
into 256 dollars for you that's it and
that's that
i also want to thank cbd lion the best
and now they're surgery tested now i
could really talk some [__]
tell you what i think about cbd lion
tremendous
whether it's the gummy bear the
kinesiology tape
the pills the the extra strength cream
the chocolate the vapor i mean listen
any way you want it
your days are complaining over go to cbd
lion just read
read up on cbn cbd cby
read up learn learn the advantages
how they can help you see how cbd lion
they break it down for you it's that
simple you just gotta read
get knowledgeable what are you gonna do
go to a liquor store you're gonna go to
a shoe store
some [__] bodega and buy it from some
guy that don't know
give yourself a break go to cd go to cbd
line right now
press in joey or church and get 20 off
it's that [__] simple all right
that's it and that's that i love you
guys
have a great week i'll be back monday
tip
top [__] magoo ready for
another fun-filled day with you
[__] all right
i love you guys have a great day stay
black
there you go
[Music]
so
you